es ist das ende einer wilden
verfolgungsjagd ein autodieb flüchtet
vor der polizei und rast in krise
überschwemmt
rückblick die polizei verfolgt mit einem
hubschrauber in einem vorort von seattle
im us bundesstaat washington ein
gestohlenes fahrzeug mit zwei autodieben
doch die verdächtigen merken ist und
lassen das auto mitten auf der straße
stehen sie suchen sich ein weiteres
fahrzeug für ihrer flucht einer der
männer kann verhaftet werden der andere
entkommt und zerrt an einer kreuzung
eine frau aus ihrem geländewagen das
weinrote auto wird von polizeiwagen
eingekeilt
doch der verdächtige rand eines der
polizeiautos und
nach kurzer fahrt versucht der mann das
auto erneut zu wechseln
das scheint nicht zu klappen die flucht
im weinroten suv geht weiter
doch dann macht der autodieb den
entscheidenden fehler er biegt in eine
sackgasse ab hier ist die straße
überschwemmt und wird zum fluss der die
brast mitten ins wasser und setzt fest
so kann er von den beamten verhaftet
werden die autobesitzer und ein polizist
werden mit der filmreifen
verfolgungsjagd leicht verletzt
[Musik]